on va passer au dos du jour on va
évoquer la tempête Siarane qui inquiète
des millions de Français en particulier
dans l'ouest de la France dans certaines
villes même ici par en île defance faut
pas trop sortir ce 100 km c'est bien s
et surtout pour ceux qui ont des
moumoutes
attention tu retrouve terminé là à cause
des arbres surtoutou parce que comme il
a fait très chaud les arbres sont son
encore t il a plus de prise au vent les
arbres sont t fu donc il fait attention
Daniel n'enlève pas ta culotte merci
dans certaines VI mais non pas ce soir
pas pendant la
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tempête ah tu prends un peu plus dans la
taté là allez euh dans certaines villes
des rafales de vent pourrai atteindre
jusqu'à 170 km/h des vagues pourrai
atteindre les 10 m alors faut-il
craindre cette fameuse tempête parce que
là on rigole mais je peux vous dire on
est on est tous inquiier pour ce soir
comment s'en protéger combien de temps
elle sera là aussi parce qu'on sait pas
combien de temps ça passe une tempête
petit recap on aura lo spadafor j'adore
loï en plus c'est lui qui av fait
rappelez
quand vous savez quand ils avaient piégé
je sais plus quelle chaîne là avec reméy
gaillard je sais plus quelle chaîne ils
avaient piégé tout ça bah c'est c'est
loï aussi qui avait qui était le
compliiss de de reméy c'était incroyable
ça c'était magnifique et ben donc c'est
pour ça que j'aime bien loï en plus et
je peux vous dire qu'il est très fort ah
oui merci ça va ça tu
revenu
merci vous avez sûrement entendu son nom
ces derniers jours la tempte kan la
tempête karane kirane une tempête qui
s'apprête à traverser l'Atlantique et à
frapper notamment le nord-ouest du pays
dès ce soir certains parlent de bombe
météorologique et si l'inquiétude est au
plus haut point c'est parce que la
tempête kirane devrait être très
violente on attend des vents de 170 km/h
et des vague de plus de 10 m alors que
plusieurs départements ont été placés en
vigilance rouge certains habitants se
préparent à l'affronter là je vais aller
acheter des sacs de sable et puis je
vais bâcher rafale de 180 kmh vague de
10 m de haut le point sur la tempête
carane qui va s'abattre ce soir sur la
France merci loï d'être avec nous loï
spadaforora expert météorologique et
météorologue on dit
meroto de quoi météorologue
météorologique météorologue ouais merci
l c'était énorme par que tu avais fait
crémir ouais c'était un moment assez
sympa de télévision on va dire ah
c'était fou c'est quoi une tempête ben
une tempête on appelle tempête en fait
Royal euh on appelle une tempête donc un
phénomène venteux qui produit des
rafales de vent au moins supérieur à à
100 km/h donc c'est le seuil pour parler
de tempête en France et donc là jusqu'à
180 kmh attendu on est sur une tempête
de très forte intensité al on rigolait
il y a un instant mais c'est quand même
un truc de fou alors est-ce que pourquoi
on en parle autant parce que vraiment à
chaque fois c'est vrai qu'on nous
annonce souvent des tempêtes et j'ai
envie de dire parfois c'est c'est une
tempête dans un verre d'eau là c'est une
vraie tempête là il parle de bon
météorologique c'est un terme d'ailleurs
c'est oui alors bon c'est un terme un
petit peu ça a pas vraiment de
signification scientifique hein mais on
est effectivement sur un creusement
despressionnaire très creux au moment
d'ailleurs où l'on se parle je crois
qu'on a atteint les 960 hectopascal donc
en fait plus la dépression est creuse
plus elle est potentiellement intense là
on devrait atteindre dans la nuit un
creusement autour des 950 heectopascal
donc ça générera des rafales de vent
tempétuuse sur un large car nord-ouest
de la France notamment de la Bretagne et
la Normandie et on redoute voilà RAF qui
atteindront qui dépasseront sans doute
les 150 km/h donc on va on va parler de
ce que ça peut produire dans un instant
et comment se protéger bien entendu euh
ça va toucher quelles zones sert les
plus touchées alors les zones les plus
touchées ben on le voit sur la carte
hein c'est véritablement de la Bretagne
à la Normandie donc on a trois
départements bien cblé dans ces
départements-l on peut atteindre des
rafales de 130 à 140 km/h dans les
terrains et sur les zones littorales on
dépassera sans doute les 150 on peut
atteindre jusqu'à 180 km/h au large des
côtes donc c'est véritablement sur cette
zone du nord-ouest de la France mais
vous le voyez aussi ailleurs on a des
rafales de vent en temp petiuse
également dans le Bassin
parisien même à Paris
C dans le Sud-Ouest et puis surtout ce
qui est important aussi de souligner
mais je pense qu'on y rendra après les
vagues et une deuxème voir une troème
tempête successive ce weekend ce weekend
encore ah ouais qui sera dans la même
région qui sera exactement dans la même
région qui touchera peut-être aussi
davantage l'ocitanie qui est épargné par
cette première tempête qui sera aussi
violente alors fort heureusement elle
sera quand même de moins forte intens
cité a priori mais du coup évidemment on
redoute des dégâts sur cette première
tempête ce qui veut dire que la deuxème
et la troisème qui vont arriver derrière
ça risque de faire de la casse sur la
casse alors justement quels sont les
risques de cette tempête ben clairement
en fait face à ces vents d'une telle
intensité on peut avoir de nombreux
arbres déracinés des arbres couchés sur
des maisons on peut avoir des toitures
sévèrement endommagées et et oui tu en
parlais des des vagues le littoral
l'ensemble du littoral en fait est
exposé à des vagues submersion des
vagues de 6 à 8 m parfois plus de de 10
m aussi au large donc on a un risque de
submersion marine sur l'ensemble du
littoral alors
euh quand vous dites il va y avoir des
des des des dégâts importants qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire euh parce que on nous
dit de pas sortir de chez nous et cetera
euh qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire même chez
nous est-ce qu'il faut est-ce que il y a
il y a des risques même pour les gens
qui seraient chez eux calefeutrés oui
ben déjà il faut être sûr d'être dans un
bâtiment suffisamment sécurisé si je
peux dire hein une maison évidemment
avec un toit il faut éviter
impérativement de prendre la route ça
c'est sûr éviter les zones boisées
éviter le bord de mer rester chez soi et
ne se déplacer que vraiment en cas
d'absolue nécessité B sinon faut pas
bouger du tout qu pas prendre la voiture
sinon faut pas bouger alors après c'est
pas un événement qui va durer forcément
très longtemps ce serait vers quelle
heure alors justement ben ça là c'est en
train de se mettre en place he l'Irlande
a été touché en fin d'après-midi la
déession Irlande il a eu quoi comme
dégâts en Irlande bah il y a eu des
dégâts sur des toitures des arbres
déracinés de nombreuses copures de
courant des inondations aussi et donc
c'est c'est surtout cette nuit au cours
de la nuit prochaine que ça sera le plus
intense on va dire entre minuit et 6h du
matin la 7 ouais cette nuit-là et ça
peut perdurer jusqu'à 9h du matin au
niveau de des Haut- de France d'accord
quelles sont les les autorités en place
et les différentes régions elles font
quoi pour éviter voilà des des des
grosses inondations ou des choses comme
ça qu'est-ce qu'elles peuvent faire ben
déjà là on a une une information
préventive c'est pas toujours le cas
hein malheureusement parce que dans
d'autres phénomènes météorologiques en
Occitanie ou ailleurs parfois la
vigilance rouge elle arrive quand le
phénomène est terminé là on a la chance
d'avoir une vigilance rouge préventive
donc ça permet de communiquer
d'expliquer aux gens justement qu'il
faut se montrer particulièrement prudent
et les autorités ben je pense qu'elles
ont réagi à conséquence hein il y a des
hélicoptères qui sont mobilisés il y a
énormément de de dispositifs de pompiers
déployés sur place en en prévention des
éventuels dégâts alors euh justement il
il y a 3200 pompiers ce qui est
historique et moi je voulais vous
reposer une question sur la double
tempête parce qu'en 99 la gigantesque
tempête en France rappelons-nous he 92
morts en France et énormément d'arbres
déracinés qui étaient tombés sur des
habitations c'était une tempête puilotre
et là vous avez évoqué donc cette double
tempête est-ce que vous craignez un
phénomène comme cette tempête historique
de 1999 alors en terme d'intensité et
détendue on n'est pas sur un phénomène
comme 99 99 ça concerne les 2 tiers de
la France il y a énormément de dégâts
sur de grandes superficies là on le voit
le phénomène très intense il est quand
même très localisé sur TR quatre
départements évidemment que les autres
départements seront aussi touchés hein
mais de façon moins importante et la
deuxième tempête sous surveillance c'est
plutôt entre samedi et dimanche donc ça
laissera quand même si je peux dire
quelques heures voir quelques jours de
répi avant de prendre la deuxième qui
sera on se le dit clairement beaucoup
moins forte quand même mais pardon en
terme d'intensité localement elle est
aussi forte qu'en 99 alors en terme
d'intensité en 99 on a dépassé les 200
km/h donc c'est pareil c'est pas
vraiment comparable par contre sur ces
territoires là précisément on pourrait
battre oui des records de rafale de
vente empêcheuse pour les voitures
est-ce qu' on peut essayer de les
rentrer le plus possible on peut les
laisser dehors et cetera ah bah oui les
voitures l'idéal si on a des garages
c'est le mieux et si on est obligé de
les laisser dehors de préférence pas
sous un arbre évidemment c'est ça ou
donc c'est vraiment ouis c'est c'est
très ça peut être compliqué on peut se
réveiller demain avec une France qui a
été énormément touchée ouais vraiment ah
ouais ouais ouais ouais oui là où il
faut faire très attention c'est que ce
soir on prévoit vous allez me le
confirmer de vagues en fait de moment et
il est serait trop imprudent de
considérer après le premier moment que
la tempête est passée parce que j'ai
compris que la deuxème vague de dans
durant la nuit serait encore plus
puissante entre minuit 1h du matin et 6h
du matin ouais c'est ça en fait au
moment où la dépression en fait circule
on a un premier passage venteux puis un
deuxième passage venteux à l'arrière
donc vraiment le créneau en fait on va
dire où il faut être prudent c'est à
partir de maintenant jusqu'à au moins
demain 9h du matin en réalité il y aura
même encore du vent soutenu toute la
matinée jusqu'à midi et la grande
différence avec 99 c'est qu'à l'époque
il y avait pas les dispositifs de
sécurité tout le monde avait été très
très surpris là il y a une grande
vigilance on a l'impression que vous
utilisez les mêmes les mêmes modes que
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis où on a
tendance à faire très très peur aux gens
pour les obliger à rester chez eux et
souvent les les jefin je veux pas
envoyer le message contraire mais
souvent on en fait beaucoup plus que la
réalité pour justement faire en sorte
que les gens soient très prudents mais
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux en faire
plus que la réalité oui vous avez dit
qu'on pouvait pas forcément anticiper
les tempêtes est-ce que ça veut dire que
dans quelques jours on peut avoir une
tempête qui arrive par surprise et qui
fait des dégâts monstrueux je crois que
ça a été le cas à capulco il y a eu des
des morts là il y a quelques jours
est-ce qu'en France il peut y avoir une
tempête surprise sans prévenir comme ça
non alors aujourd'hui en en France et
plus largement dans le monde on arrive à
anticiper ce type de phénomène jusqu'à 5
à 7 jours on identifie le phénomène
après pour être vraiment très précis on
va dire à l'infralocal dans des
départements c'est plutôt 24 à 48 he
avant là on sait que celle de samedi et
dimanche il y a très peu de chance que
le phénomène s'intensifie d'ici là on
parle plus plutôt de Rafal voisine des
100 à 110 km/h pour samedi dimanche
contre 150 à 180 j'ai une question d'une
ami qui me dit est-ce que ça touchera
que la France métropole puisque c'est an
hiidalgo qui demande si Tahiti pourrait
être alors par celle-ci non hein mais pe
par d'autres hein on nespère pas parce
qu'on on abbrasse tous nos amis de de
Tahiti bien entendu on n esppère pas ils
sont ont déjà hiidalgo ça ferait
beaucoup oui on voit dans les
départements bretons là les Côtes
d'Armor c'est la première alerte rouge
de leur histoire et on parlait tout à
l'heure de vague de submersion est-ce
que vous pensez qu' en Bretagne
notamment il y a une vague gigantesque
qui pourrait envahir les ports parce
qu'on a vu que dans les ports il se
calfultre il protège les bateaux ça on
le craint vraiment ça on le craint
vraiment oui parce qu'en fait le pour
pour vous dire le on est sur l'échelle
de Beaufort sur les prévisions on est
sur le max d'intensité de l'échelle de
Beaufort bas de 1 jusqu'à 12 on est sur
des vents de force 12 c'est-à-dire des
vents de force ouragan au large hein
avec des vents pour faire tout un
fromage avec les chales de Beaufor
oh avec des v moyens donc autour des 118
km/h ce qui est énorme et effectivement
la le con on va dire les plusieurs
facteurs parce qu'en plus de ça on n pas
parlé des précipitations mais il va
aussi fortement pleuvoir donc on a les
fortes pluies avec un risque de cru le
phénomène de V de VAC surmersion et en
plus la Rafal vent empétuess donc c'est
un cocktail vraiment explosif dans les
événements comme ça pour les
particuliers et les professionnels ça va
être catastrophique même si on peut s'y
préparer en terme financier est-ce que
vous qui connaissez un peu tout parce
que vous êtes dans le milieu est-ce que
vous pensez que on peut dire aujourd'hui
aux gens que les assurances vont
vraiment tout couvrir quand c'est des
catastrophes comme ça naturelles bah
effectivement je suis bien placé pour le
savoir je sais qu'en général c'est très
compliqué de se faire indemniser même en
cas de reconnaissance de catastrophe
naturelle c'est des procédures qui
durent plusieurs mois parfois même en
année donc ce qui est sûr c'est que donc
là il y a des gens si pour pour non j'ai
pas le mot sens-toi peu non pardon je
bug
French
[Applaudissements]
pour le
peu pour le peu pour le peu que
quelqu'un pour le peu c'est pas le mot
mais pour peu que quelqu'un ait une
assurance un peu légère vous pensez
qu'ils peuvent du coup tout perdre il y
a un risque de perdre certaines choses
c'està-dire à l'intérieur de la maison
alors après ce qui est infrastructure en
général c'est couvert de dans tous les
cas par la la l'assurance de risque
naturell et de catastrophhe naturelles
après àintérieur une maison qui est
inondée vous perdez votre votre
ordinateur qui a k vous avez pas la
facture des choses comme ça là oui
évidemment c'est toujours compqué parce
que généralement dans votre cas c'est la
petite étoile qui est en bas du contrat
j'ai un ami per l'équilibre aussi j'ai
un ami qui me dit je suis étonné que
votre expert météo qui est excellent
n'est pas précisé que la France est très
en retard sur la construction de Panic
Room et autrre refuges contre les
tempêtes à ce jour aucun bâtiment civil
n'est sécurisé à 100 % mis à part la
culotte de Daniel qui a rest intact et
inf franchiss depuis 40 ans je vous jure
qu'il y a vraiment un mec qui
mécritchiss depu c'est Fabien deree non
mais alors non mais c'est pas con ça oui
non mais bien sûr alors après ça là on
est plus sur des questions d'urbanisme
même moi mon domaine c'est plus la météo
mais c'est vrai que c'est lié mais on
n'est pas en retard que sur ça on est
aussi en retard sur beaucoup de choses
sur l'aménagement du territoire face au
risque inondation il y a ce facteur
aussi de de Rafale devant mais je pense
que c'est des projets et des
aménagements qui coûtent des millions
voire des milliards d'euros et moi je
dis alors juste on voit souvent des gens
pendant les tempêtes clouer des matelas
sur les fenêtres et cetera est-ce que ça
sert à quel chose bois est que les
fenêtres de bois des trucs on va dire
que ça peut limiter la casse mais quand
on a si les rafales de vent se
confirment et qu'on a du 140 km/h dans
l'intérieur des terres quand un habite
en hauteur un immeuble qui habite très
haut ça doit faire flipper de fou si ça
souffle à mort oui alors après
normalement les immeubles ils sont quand
même0 kmh un immeuble il
résiste en principe oui en principe ça
dépend comment elle été constru ex
est-ce que le réchauffement climatique
est responsable de ce genre de tempête
ou elle est juste juste normale
exceptionnelle contuépo de la prie tout
ça très bonne questionou c'est une
question
très non mais alors ce qui est paradoxal
c'est que ça faisait quand même quelques
années qu'on avait pas eu de phénomènes
aussi intens he faut monter à 2020 pour
avoir une tempête comparable alors c'est
pas au même endroit c'est la tempête
Alex qui avit frappé plutôt l'Occitanie
et la Côte d'Azur notamment mais il y a
toujours eu des tempêtes des groses temp
touour évidment il y a toujours eu des
tempêtes les tempêtes avec le
réchauffement c'est l'accélération et la
puissance aussi des des temp le
réchauffement j'ai même envie de dire
plutôt même le dérèglement climatique
euh c'est surtout qu'on va avoir des
phénomènes potentiellement de plus en
plus fréquents et on a une une
récurrence de l'intensité par exemple
moi en Méditerranée en Occitanie on a
une une recrudescence des phénomènes
météorologiques type épisode céol
épisode méditerranéen c'est lié au fait
que la température se réchauffe plus on
a d'air chaud dans l'atmosphère plus on
a d'évaporation de l'eau en Méditerranée
plus on a potentiellement carburant dans
les orages c'est évidemment la chaleur
elle est liée à l'intensité des
phénomènes et donc elles sont pas plus
violentes au fil des années parce que
vous disiez que l' plus fréquente non là
c'est sur les les 10 dernières années on
n' pas forcément observé de tempête plus
importante en France oui Daniel non non
j'étais peut-être plus fréquente que la
récurrence c'est la récurrence oui voà
ouais très bien bon ben écoutez donc ce
soir si vous avez un conseil à donner à
nos téléspectateurs ce serait ne pas
sortir de chez soi qu-ce qu'il y a des
ministrre de l'Intérieur rester voilà
rester abrité au moins jusqu'à demain en
fin de matinée et évidemment voilà
éviter au maximum de vous déplacer voilà
merci merci en tout cas d'avoir avec
nous et franchement c'était cétait
top
merci les chéris